NUANCED.
MIKE?
>> Mike: BENJAMIN HALL IN
LONDON.
THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S UPCOMING
MEETING WITH A CHINESE
COUNTERPART COULD BE A LOT MORE
CONTENTIOUS THAN EITHER ONE OF
THEM HAS PLANNED.
THAT IS PARTIALLY BECAUSE OF
INCREASING TENSIONS BETWEEN THE
U.S. AND CHINA OVER TRADE.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE TELLS US
TONIGHT NATIONAL SECURITY IS
ALSO BECOMING A MAJOR ISSUE IN
THE RELATIONSHIP.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 25
YEARS, THE ASIA-PACIFIC SUMMIT
ENDED WITHOUT A FORMAL JOINT
STATEMENT AMONG THE 21 LITERS,
CHINA WAS
APPARENTLY THE HOLDOUT OVER
TRADE DISAGREEMENTS.
>> IN THE PRESIDENT'S WORDS,
CHINA HAS TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF THE
UNITED STATES FOR MANY, MANY
YEARS.
THOSE DAYS ARE OVER.
IT IS BECAUSE THE CHINESE
PRESIDENT ADDRESSED A STRATEGIC
DILEMMA.
>> Translator: MANKIND HAS
ONCE AGAIN REACHED A CROSSROADS.
WHICH DIRECTION SHOULD WE
CHOOSE?
COOPERATION OR CONFRONTATION?
>> AFTER THE U.S.-CHINA CLASH AT
APEX, THEY ARE FOCUSED ON THE
UPCOMING G20 SUMMIT IN
ARGENTINA, WHERE PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND XI ARE EXPECTED TO MEET.
RECENTLY SIGNING CYBERSECURITY
LEGISLATION, THE PRESIDENTS LAY
DOWN A MARKER.
>> CHINA WANTS TO MAKE A DEAL,
THEY SENT A LIST OF THINGS THAT
THEY ARE WILLING TO DO, WHICH
WAS A LARGE LIST.
AND JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE.
>> CHINA, IN MY OPINION, IS THE
BIGGEST NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT
TO LONG-TERM THIS COUNTRY WILL
EVER FACE.
NUMBER ONE, TWO, THREE PRIORITY
WHEN IT COMES TO INTELLIGENCE
GATHERING IS AMERICA WHEN I COME
TO CHINA.
>> BOB ANDERSON, FORMER A CYSTIC
COMIC ASSISTANT FBI DIRECTOR
SPECIALIZING IN HACKING, SPINE,
AND ESPIONAGE.
HE SAID THE BUREAU IS BADLY
OUTNUMBERED BY CHINA.
>> MINISTRY OF STATE SECURITY,
THINK OF IT AS THEIR FBI WITHOUT
ANY RULES.
THERE ARE 35,000 MEN AND WOMEN
IN THE FBI.
THERE ARE 400,000 IN THE AM AS
F.
>> >> OCTOBER, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INDICTED A MEMBER FOR
ALLEGEDLY TARGETING U.S.
AEROSPACE AND AVIATION
TECHNOLOGY.
EARLIER THIS MONTH, THE
DEPARTMENT TOOK THE UNUSUAL STEP
OF SINGLING OUT A TINY STATE
OWNED COMPANY AFTER A 20 MONTH
INVESTIGATION.
THE FBI NOW HAS CHINESE ECONOMIC
ESPIONAGE CASES IN ALMOST ALL 50
STATES.
WHILE IT'S HARD TO QUANTIFY THE
ECONOMIC COST, THIS INDEPENDENT
COMMISSION ON INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY THEFT FOUND THE DAMAGE
COULD RUN AS HIGH AS 600 BILLION
ANNUALLY.
ANDERSON SAID IT DOESN'T STOP
THERE.
>> SPECIFICALLY WITH CHINA AND
RUSSIA, THERE HAS BEEN ALLIANCES
BETWEEN THEM.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT WITH A
WEARY EYE BECAUSE WHEN YOU PUT
TWO COUNTRIES OF THAT
MAGNITUDE WITH THE AMOUNT OF
INTELLIGENCE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
THEY HAVE AGAINST OUR
COUNTRY, IT IS UNBELIEVABLY
SIGNIFICANT.
>> AND RESPONSIVE CHINESE
EMBASSY PROVIDED FOX NEWS
WITH A 70 PAGE DOCUMENT THAT
ALLEGES THE CURRENT U.S.
ADMINISTRATION STIGMATIZES CHINA
BY ACCUSING IT OF INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY THEFT, ADDING THE